طرته ظروف الحرب التي مزقت بلده الى بيع
الحلويات على دراجه هوائيه لكسب قوتها
ضحيه نغم انفجر بجانبه
باللون
تبعه زمان
بعد ان بطير ساقه اضطر ابو محمد الذي يعمل
في الاصل نجارا في الغوطه الشرقيه الى
اعاده ترتيب حياته من جديد
في سوريا بسبب الالغام الارضيه سلاح
عشوائي بطبيعته يفتك بالمدنيين ويفعل ذلك
حتى بعد عقود من زرعه في الارض
حروفها والله وانا هذيك النهار
يا
علي عمي طنجه في المطبخ كلهم مهطي
ومشيوا ما شفت الا انا شيء اجاني حجرها
هيك انا واقفه هناك اجاني حجر
القصفي والضربات الجويه المسؤوله عن مقتل
النسبه الاكبر من نصف مليون سوري لقوا
حدفهم بسبب الحرب في السنوات الاخيره لكن
المخلفات المتفجره التي زرعتها جميع
الاطراف في الصراع المستمر منذ 11 عاما
تتسبب في المزيد من الوفيات في سوريا اكثر
من اي مكان اخر في العالم حسب ما تقول
الامم المتحده من خلال عام 2022 بالغوطه
الشرقيه فانا بحدود تم ااه العثور على
بحدود 300 رغم مين دل ااه 1500 ابو ناس في
همم بحدود 14 صاروخ وقزيه في مجدي تهديء
الملايين من الانغام الارضيه
حياتها سكان العديد من المناطق في سوريا
يحتاج كل واحد منها ان ينزع يدويا
[موسيقى]
وعندما يعود الناجحون واللاجئون السوريون
الى مناطقهم سيواجهون هذه المعضله هناك
جهد كبير يجب ان يتم في اطار التوعيه
بمخاطر الالغام المضاده للافراد بالاضافه
الى نعها وتنظيف البلاد منها وقد يستغرق
الامر عقودا من الزمن قبل ان يتم اعلان
خلو سوريا بشكل كامل من قاتل المجهول
الهويه زرع الموتى والظمار